हेलो गैस वेलकम तू अवर युटुब चैनल अकादमी
तो मेरा नाम है आयुष पाठक और मैं आपको इस
सीरीज में ट्रेड देने वाला हूं नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी के बड़े में तो सबसे पहले जैसा
की आप लोग जानते ही होंगे की हमारा चैनल
है तो उसे पे हम काफी साड़ी सीरीज लॉन्च
कर चुके हैं ऑलरेडी जैसे काली ने उसके
फ्री सीरीज हो गई आपके लिए जिसको हम
कैप्सूल कोर्स के नाम से जानते हैं
क्योंकि हमारा साथ से 15 दिन का एक तरीके
का कोर्स होता है इसमें हम फ्री में आपके
लिए काफी साड़ी क्योंकि कंटेंट हो सकता है
उसको ऑर्गेनाइज करके आपके लिए परण करते
हैं तो कालीकट ऑलरेडी हो चुका है जो की
सचिन सर के द्वारा हुआ है और पाइथन का भी
हो चुका है जो हार्दिक सर के द्वारा हो
चुका है आपके लिए एक कैप्सूल कोर्स
कंप्लीट तो ये भी एक तरीके से का सकते हैं
इसमें हम कंप्लीट करने वाले हैं नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी को बेसिक लेवल से लेकर ठीक
लेवल तक खाने का मतलब ये है की अगर आपको
कुछ पहले से नहीं आता है तो उसमें कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है हमारा बी है ये विजन भी है
ये इस तरीके से आपको पटाया जाए की आपको
बेसिक से चीजों को चीजों को समझ आपको
अच्छे से ए जाए कोई दिक्कत आपको ना हो और
हमारी कोई भी सीरीज में आपको ज्यादातर कोई
पिछले ज्ञान की जरूर नहीं होगी मतलब अगर
आपको एडवांस कर रहे हैं तो उसका बेसिक भी
पहले हमें सिखाएंगे तो को दिक्कत जो है
आपको नहीं होने वाली है तो मैं आपके थ्रू
करने वाला नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी के बड़े में
सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट कैसे करेंगे हम
स्टार्ट करेंगे बेसिक समझना से नेटवर्किंग
के ठीक है सबसे पहले हमारा जो पांचवें
होगा वो कुछ इस तरीके का होगा पहले हम
बेसिक समझेंगे नेटवर्क
समझना के बाद हम थोड़े बेसिक नेटवर्क
एनीमेशन समझेंगे जैसे नेटवर्क स्कैन कैसे
किया जाते हैं उसमें और चीज क्या होती है
मतलब सारे टर्म जितने एयरपोर्ट प्रोटोकॉल
सब कुछ हम थोड़ा अच्छे से चीजों को और
डिस्कवर कैसे होता है नेटवर्क में
डिस्कवरिंग पार्ट जो होता है वो कैसे होता
है एन्यूमरेशन होता है वो कैसे होता है
दोनों समझेंगे अब देखिए डिस्कवरी में अंतर
है डिस्कवरिंग मतलब की कितने लोग हैं
कितने क्लाइंट है ये इस टाइप की चीज है और
इनोवेशन मतलब हम प्रोटोकॉल से थोड़ा दीप
में जाएंगे की कैसे आईएनएनयूमरेशन होता है
और बाकी चीज उनमें होती है जैसे एसएनबी हो
गया या एचटीटीपी हो गया इन चीजों के बड़े
में हम समझेंगे डिस्कवरिंग में और इसके
बड़े में करेंगे मतलब कुछ बदलती उसको भी
एक्सपर्ट करेंगे हम ये नेटवर्क की आम फेमस
होती है इनके अलावा और भी जो चीज हो शक्ति
है एक्सप्लोइटेशन लेवल पे और थोड़ा ऊपर
लेवल पे इतना आपको समझ में आता है
स्टार्टिंग से कर करेंगे उन चीजों को तो
आपको दिक्कत ही नहीं होगी अब एक चीज ये
इंपॉर्टेंट बात की हमारा अप्रोच क्या होगा
तो बात करें अप्रोच यही तो हम जितना भी
बेसिक रहेगा थ्योरी वो तो कर करेंगे तो उन
चीजों को हम लैब के साथ करेंगे लेफ्ट के
साथ कैसे
विंडोज खोल राखी है पहले मैं आपको एक
ओवरव्यू देता हूं अगर आपको नहीं पता है तो
वेबसाइट सिंपल अप ओपन कर लेंगे अगर आप
अकाउंट बना चुके हैं उसे कर चुके हैं तो
अच्छी बात है नहीं किया तो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है आपको यहां पे ओपन करके अकाउंट बना
लेना है ठीक है इसके बाद अगर आप यहां लर्न
हो जाएंगे लर्न जो ऑप्शन है यहां पर इसमें
आकर आपको यहां पर मॉडल्स हो जाना है यहां
पर ये मॉडल्स लिखा हुआ है इस पे मोडल और
यहां पर अक्सर हमने सारे मॉडल्स जो है ओपन
हो जाएंगे तो इनमें हम बेसिक अभी दो
मॉडल्स को टाइट प्रेस चल रहे हैं पहले
आपका ये वाला है नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल्स जो
की मैंने यहां पे खोल रखा है इसमें ये कुछ
रूम हैं और फिर अगला आपका जो मैंने अभी के
लिए टारगेट किया हुआ है आपका होगा नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी वाला ये वाला ठीक है ये रहा
टोटल जिसमें कुछ कुछ बेसिक रूम है ठीक है
तो अब इन हम जितने भी थ्योरी को कर करते
रहेंगे उन थ्योरी के साथ-साथ हम इनको करते
रहेंगे इनको मैं आपके सामने एकदम डायरेक्ट
करूंगा यानी मतलब इनमें जितनी मुझे
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज लगेगी मैं सब कुछ कर
करूंगा और जरूर पड़ेगी तो मैं आपके सामने
ही पढ़ूंगा इन चीजों को ताकि आपको दिक्कत
ना हो ठीक है और आपको समझ में से कुछ
अच्छे से मैं समझते हुए चलूंगा आपको एक-एक
चीज कहेंगे अब एक बात और यहां पर मैं कहना
चाहूंगा की पहले चीज तो हम इस सीरीज को
नहीं रख रहे हैं हम इस सीरीज को युटुब पर
पूरा करें अगर आपको समझ में ए रहा है उसको
लाइक करें और कमेंट करें चीजों को अब एक
साथ में और कहना चाहूंगा की आपके मां में
ये सवाल ए सकता है की टाइम कितने लगेगा तो
मेरे ख्याल से ये जितना आप सपोर्ट देंगे
उसपे डिपेंड करता है की ये सीरीज कितनी
लंबी चलेगी क्योंकि अनलिमिटेड हो शक्ति है
मैंने आपको बेसिक सीखने वाला किया है वो
जरूर सिखाऊंगा उसके ऊपर जितना आपका सपोर्ट
रहेगा उतना हम बढ़ते जाएंगे आगे और इसमें
यदि आपको ध्यान रखना है की हमारी लाइफ
क्लास नहीं है रिकॉर्डिंग है तो ओबवियसली
हमारा टाइम कम लगेगा लेकिन आपको पूरा टाइम
देना है खाने का मतलब क्या जो चीज मैं कर
रहा हूं आपको उसको साथ में करनी है अपना
दिमाग लगाना है आपको जरूर पड़ती है आप
वीडियो को पॉज कीजिए पॉज कीजिए हम चेंज
करेंगे लेफ्ट करेंगे तो उनको पॉज करें और
वहां पे अपना दिमाग लगा के सोचेंगे इसमें
क्या आंसर हो सकता है कैसे हो सकता है
चीजों को ऐसे लेट करें अपने मां में
विकल्प करें तो उसमें आपका ही फायदा होगा
आप वीडियो कर करने की कोई मतलब नहीं है
वीडियो एक्स थ्री एक्स देख लेंगे उसका
फायदा नहीं है ठीक है तो अब क्या करना है
आराम से वीडियो को पॉज करके जहां-जहां
जरूर है वीडियो को आपको पोस्ट करनी है तो
हम प्रेजेंटेशन से लेक लेफ्ट से लेकर जिन
चीजों को जरूर है सब का इस्तेमाल करेंगे
ठीक है
मैं आपको कुछ और दिखता हूं हां एक एक डाउट
और मैं आपके लिए बोल डन की कई लोग कई हो
सकता है की जब ट्राई एक्ने से रेडी करना
है इस टाइप की चीज करनी है तो आपकी वीडियो
का फायदा क्या है तो वीडियो का दो-तीन
फायदा होने वाला है पहले यह की हम सिर्फ
ट्री डिपेंड रहेंगे अपने प्रेजेंटेशन अपनी
चीज प्रैक्टिकल वह सभी मैं आपको बताने
वाला हूं ठीक है इसके साथ-साथ ट्राई हैक
मी पे भी कई सारे ऐसे लेफ्ट से जो पेड़
लेफ्ट है जैसे यहां पर तीन लैब ये नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी है जो मोडल है फंडामेंटल्स
वाला इसमें यहां पर तीन लैब जो नीचे वाला
है वो तीन पेड़ है विप ठीक है यहां
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी वाले में भी नीचे वाले
ने जो है वो पेड़ है ठीक है तो मैं आपको
प्रीमियम अकाउंट से पीरियड वाले एफ भी
कराऊंगा ये ऑलरेडी
समझ सकते हैं चीजों को अब फिर अगर आपके
पास अकाउंट है आप परचेज कर सकते हैं तो वो
तो बहुत अच्छी बात है साथ में कर सकते हैं
नहीं तो आप देख के काफी कुछ ऐसे सिख सकते
हैं क्योंकि इसमें आपको बस पूरा मौका
रहेगा वीडियो को पोज करने का सोने का
दिमाग लगाने का सही चलेंगे इसको आप अपनी
तरफ से सॉल्व कर सकें फिर मैं तो इसलिए
सॉल्व करूंगा ये करूंगा तो इससे आप सिख
सकते हैं चाहे आपके पास पेड़ अकाउंट हो या
ना हो ये आपको मिलेगा देखिए यहां पे भी
नेटवर्क से q2 वाले में सिर्फ तीन रूम
फ्री है बाकी शायद जितने यहां पे सब पेड़
तो साड़ी पेड़ चीज आपको यहां पर फ्री में
सीखने को मिल जाएंगे यह पता रहेगा आपका
हमारी सीरीज को लॉन्च करें मतलब फॉलो करने
का ठीक है तो चैनल सब्सक्राइब
नहीं होगी लेकिन जो भी होगी उसमें आपको
निचोड़ के इनफॉरमेशन मिलेगी ठीक है तो
बेसिक कॉन्सेप्ट शुरू कर सकते हैं यहां पर
और जितने भी चीज डाउट मतलब जितने भी
क्वेश्चंस की हम लाइव नहीं है पर जितने
क्वेश्चन में पूछता हूं अपने मां में उनका
आंसर जरूर सोचना है ठीक है चलिए बात कर
लेते हैं कंप्यूटर नेटवर्किंग होती क्या
है ठीक तो कंप्यूटर नेटवर्क इंटरनेट
वर्किंग डिवाइस डेट कैन एक्सचेंज डाटा और
शेर रिसोर्सेस खाने का मतलब क्या मतलब ये
की कई सारे जो कंप्यूटर होते हैं डिवाइसेज
होते हैं जो आपस में कनेक्ट होते हैं अब
कैसे कनेक्ट होते हैं वो आगे पढ़ लेंगे
लेकिन कनेक्ट होते हैं अन्य हो ठीक है
वॉयरसली या फिर केवल के थ्रू कैसे भी
कनेक्ट है आपस में डाटा को चेंज कर सकते
हैं अब वो डाटा कुछ नहीं हो सकता है ऐसे
हो सकता है रिक्वेस्ट भी हो सकता है पर
ऐसे डिस्टेंस आपस में कनेक्ट है सिस्टम
मतलब कोई भी चीज कंप्यूटर सिस्टम पे बात
नहीं आई है उसको हम एक नेटवर्क कहते हैं
ठीक है ये होता है हमारा बेसिक कंप्यूटर
नेटवर्किंग
अब एक इंपॉर्टेंट सवाल की नेटवर्किंग
पढ़ने की जरूर क्या है ठीक है तो
नेटवर्किंग पढ़ने की जरूर देखिए एक तो अलग
चीज हो गई की नेटवर्किंग के फोर फील्ड में
आपको जाना है और नेटवर्क इंजीनियर है इन
सब साइड आपको ज्यादा बढ़ाना है तो वो एक
अलग चीज हो गई लेकिन अगर आपको साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से हम बात
करें तो नेटवर्क की क्या जरूर है तो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से नेटवर्किंग
बहुत ही इंपॉर्टेंट चीज पद जाता है ठीक है
उसे तरह रीजन ये है की आप कोई भी तरीके का
एक्सप्लोजन कीजिए आप चाहे कोई लेफ्ट फिट
करके प्रोटेक्शन करना है अपने सिस्टम पे
या आप कोई पिंटरेस्ट कर रहे हैं तो उसमें
हर चीज में आपको नेटवर्क कहीं अच्छे से
मिलता है एग्जांपल अगर मैं आपको इजी पीएफ
एग्जाम का डन जो की एक रियल वर्ल्ड
कॉन्टैक्ट को सिम्युलेट करते हैं चाहे आप
पीएमपीटी की बात कर सकते हैं अलग की
पीएनपीटी आइडिया नहीं है पर मेरे ख्याल से
इनमें भी ऐसे ही होता है की आपको एक
नेटवर्क में कनेक्ट कर दिया जाता है अब वो
कैसे करते हैं वो आगे हम समझ लेंगे कैसे
एक्सटेंड होता है नेटवर्क कनेक्शन पर आपको
एक नेटवर्क में कनेक्ट कर दिया जाता है एक
कंपनी के प्राइवेट नेटवर्क में और आपको
उसे नेटवर्क के अंदर से ही चीजों को
न्यूमैरेट करके डिस्कवर करके एक्सपर्ट
करना होता है ठीक है ये जरूरी है ये जरूर
है नेटवर्किंग को पढ़ने की साइबर
सिक्योरिटी स्टूडेंट के लिए आपका
नेटवर्किंग बेसिक क्लियर नहीं होगा तब
ऑलमोस्ट कोई भी
दिक्कत होगी चाहे आप प्रोग्रामिंग सिख रहे
हो साइबर सिक्योरिटी के लिए उसने आपको
स्क्रिप्ट बनाने की कोशिश करें कोई टूल जो
ऑनलाइन वेबसाइट से इंटरेक्ट करता हूं आखिर
देखिए इधर साइड से भी इंटरेक्ट करना है
सबको नेटवर्किंग जीरो तो होने वाली है तो
इन साड़ी चीजों में आपको नेटवर्किंग की
जरूर पढ़ने वाली है प्रोडक्टिंग करने की
जरूर आपको है इस चीज को आपको समझना पड़ेगा
ठीक है अब यहां पर देखिए जुड़े एप्लीकेशन
पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से है की नेटवर्किंग की
जरूर क्या है एग्जांपल आपको नेटवर्क स्कैन
करने को अप को इनोवेशन करना हो एक्सपीडिशन
करना हो मेनू मी टेक करना हो इसके बड़े
में भी हम जानेंगे अभी पुशिंग करनी हो दो
ऑफ अटैक करना हो जी हां दोस्तों देख लीजिए
नॉलेज की बेसिक की जरूर तो होती ही होती
है ठीक है चाहे आपको
मेजर रोल प्ले करता है चाहे आपको सेल्फ
लेने हो आप अक्सर सुनते हैं सिस्टम ले
लिया चाहे आपको कोई कीट खेल रहा है कुछ भी
कर रहे हो ऐसे भी ट वाला कॉन्सेप्ट भी ऐसे
ही कम करता है ना उसे करते हैं आप नेटवर्क
में कनेक्ट होते हैं उनके वो सब भी आप
समझेंगे समझते रहेंगे और अभी आप एक जस्ट
बेसिक चीजों को समझते हुए चलते रहिए तो ये
कोई एप्लीकेशन पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से मुझे
सिक्योरिटी हमें नेटवर्क नहीं पढ़ने की
जरूर क्यों है साइबर सिक्योरिटी में ठीक
है अब बात कर लेते हैं अब इससे बड़ा कौन
सा नेटवर्क होगा सबसे बिगेस्ट एक तरीके से
आप का सकते हैं वर्ल्ड वाइड कम्युनिकेशन
नेटवर्क ही होता है इंटरनेट ठीक है
इंटरनेट मतलब ओवरऑल जो भी हमारा इस देश से
कम्युनिकेशन हो रहा है कहानी भी
कम्युनिकेशन हो रहा है वो इंटरनेट जरूरी
है ना आपका डॉक्टर उसे कर रहे हैं आप
राउटर वाले को पे करना है अपने आईएसपी को
पे कर रहे हैं ब्रॉडबैंड वाले को पे कर
रहे हैं वो किस लिए पे कर रहे हैं इंटरनेट
एक्सेस करने के लिए आप google.com लिखने
हैं आपके फोन में google.com खुला जाता है
तो बंटी है वो इंटरनेट की जरूरी हो रहा है
ये तो बेसिक चीज हैं सबको पता ही है फोन
से एक्सेस करने लैपटॉप से एक्सेस कर रहे
हैं चाहे आप आउट डिवाइसेज इस्तेमाल करें
मतलब ऐसे वीडियो ऐसे होते है ना कहानी
देखो जैसे आपकी स्मार्ट लाइट है ऐसा कुछ
हो गया जो इंटरनेट की तरफ कंट्रोल कर सकते
हैं मतलब लोकल ही नहीं बोल रहा हूं आप
कहानी बैठे हुए अपनी लाइट्स को ऑन ऑफ कर
सकते हैं कुछ भी चीज कर सकते हैं वो चीज
भी इंटरनेट के थ्रू ही चल रही है तो ओवरऑल
हर चीज इंटरनेट के थ्रू चल रही है तो चलिए
समझ गए होंगे की इंटरनेट क्या चीज है तो
आगे बढ़ते हैं हम लोग
नेक्स्ट हम लोग पहले समझ लेते हैं लिक और
इंटरफेस के बड़े में तो निक का मतलब होता
है नेटवर्क इंटरफेस कार्ड तो एक यह आपका
हार्डवेयर कंपोनेंट होता है मतलब ये
कंप्यूटर में हो गया है आपके फोन में हो
गया कहानी भी हो गया ये तरीका आप इसको चिप
का सकते हैं जो भी आप कहना चाहे आप जो
एक्सटर्नल एड्स करते हैं
उसमें भी ऐसी ही होता है ठीक है तो यार
ऐसी का कम क्या होता है और ऐसी का कम होता
है अब ये वायरलेस कम्युनिकेशन
ठीक है खाने का मतलब क्या आपको कंप्यूटर
जो है ये आप किसी वाइफ करते हैं या किसी
नेटवर्क से कनेक्ट करते हैं दोस्तों
कनेक्ट कैसे आप करते हैं जी चिप या जी
हार्डवेयर करते हैं उसको नेटवर्क इंटरफेस
कटता है ठीक है और आज जैसे आपको ये लैपटॉप
लिया तो उसने एक नेटवर्क इंटरफेस कार्ड
पहले से आता है और उसे एक नेटवर्क इंटरफेस
जो भी आप खरीदने हैं उसका एक सॉफ्टवेयर
एक मैनेजर है जो भी आप चाहे उसका एक
सॉफ्टवेयर लेवल पे इंटरफेस होता है खाने
का मतलब की आप उसे जो भी आपका कार्ड है
उसको आप उससे आप कम्युनिकेट कैसे करेंगे
वो आपकी इंटरफेस कुछ होता है ठीक है मतलब
आपका कार्ड जो भी हार्डवेयर कार्ड है जो
इस्तेमाल हो रहा है आपको नेटवर्क में
करवाने के लिए आपको नेटवर्क में
कम्युनिकेट करवाने के लिए उसका जो एक्सेस
है वो आप इंटरफेस जरूर करते हैं और इसके
एग्जांपल मैं आपको देता हूं जैसे की मैंने
यहां पर एक परफेक्ट कनेक्ट कर रखा है अपना
मोटो नाम का ठीक है तो मेरे लैपटॉप में
कैन आई सी लगा है जिसकी थ्रू मुझे वी-फी
कनेक्ट हो गया है अब अगर मैं कमांड पंप
ओपन करता हूं
और आप मैं सिंपल कमांड देता हूं आईपी
कनफ्लिक्ट ठीक है तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां
पर ए गया है तो ऊपर वाला यह मेरा स्टॉक
देखिए वायरलेस वी-फी ठीक है तो ये क्या है
ये हमारा वी-फी जो निक का जो कार्ड लगा
हुआ है उसे कार्ड का इंटरफेस है ठीक इस
इंटरफेस के थ्रू मैं देख सकता हूं की मेरा
इस टाइम करंट जो भी आईपी है वो क्या है ये
मेरा आईपीएल ठीक है और ये मेरा सबने क्लास
के बड़े में आगे बात करने वाले हैं पर
बेसिकली आपको ये समझना है की आपके निक ने
हेल्प किया मुझे नेटवर्क से कनेक्ट करने
के लिए और ये इंटरफेस इनके थ्रू मैं उनकी
डिटेल दे सकता हूं मैं उनसे कर सकता हूं
मेरे से चल सकता हूं ठीक है ये चीज मैं
आपको अगर काली पे अगर आपको देखनी हो मैं
यहां पर विंडो सिस्टम
हो जाति है
देखिए यहां पर इस तरीके से आप इंटर्नशिप
का नियम देख सकते हैं आप इंटरफेस का नियम
मां लीजिए वाईफाई जीरो
इस तरीके से इंटरफेस का इस्तेमाल देखिए
यहां पर ये मेरा आईपी एड्रेस है सिस्टम का
है ठीक है ये कैसे मैंने ओपन किया है
लेकिन इसमें लीजिए अभी के लिए तो ये ठीक
है ये कम कर रहा है क्या आपका इंटरफेस अब
इंटरफेस और ये निक के बड़े में क्या समझा
हमने इसको समझा की एक्सटर्नल जो हम
एडाप्टर खरीदने हैं वी-फी फैंटास्टिक के
लिए हो गया किसी और कम के लिए हो तो उनके
अलग-अलग लाइसेंस होते हैं उसमें हमें
अलग-अलग इंटरफेस मिलते हैं तो हमें
अलग-अलग इंटरफेस इंटरफेस ट्राई करके
अलग-अलग अटैक करने होते हैं ठीक है तो अभी
मुझे समझना जरूरी होगा और हमें ऐसा ही
करना होता है इसमें मॉनिटर मोड पैकेट
इंजेक्शन ये सब सपोर्ट करता हूं
आपको लिक के ऐसे कम करता है क्या होता है
इंटरफेस क्या होता है उसकी जानकारी होना
जरूरी है एक और इंपॉर्टेंट बात आपका एन आई
सी तो रहेगा ही रहेगा लेकिन हर एक ऐसी का
एक इंटरफेस भी रहेगा ठीक है
जरूरी नहीं है खाने का मतलब ये की आप जैसे
कोई बच्चों की मशीन चलते हैं
बॉक्स चला रहे हो तो उसके साथ साथ आपका कई
सारे मल्टीपल जो है इंटरफेस को अपने लिए
क्रिएट कर देता है जैसे की मैंने आपको
स्टार्टिंग में कहा था की ऊपर वाले ये चीज
आपको कीजिए तो मैंने इसीलिए कहा था बहुत
सारे ऐसे यहां पर जैसे ये हो गया ऐसा हो
गया ऐसे बहुत सारे यदि आप देख सकते हैं
अभी हम भैया लिखा हुआ है इस तरीके के
वर्चुअल इंटरफेस आपका जो है एमवेयर या
वर्चुलअलबॉक्स हो गया ये सब उसे करते हैं
खुद ही से ठीक है ये खुद क्रिएट करते हैं
इंटरफेस को क्योंकि मैं आप अपनी प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क्स में बता सकते हैं तो थोड़ी दीप
अलग-अलग चीज है इनके बड़े में सब
सेटिंग्स के बड़े में मैं पूछ लेट हूं
लेकिन नदी के लिए आपको ये समझना है की
एनालिसिस तो होंगे ही होंगे
लेकिन हर इंटरफेस का जरूरी है की अलग-अलग
ऐसी हो ही ठीक है ये चीज समझना जरूरी है
ठीक है वैसे यहां पे लिख दिया है जैसे
एग्जांपल
उसे करते हैं
इसी तरीके से नाम होता है हमारे इंटरफेस
का जैसा की मैंने आपको भी काली भी दिखाए
लेने जीरो करके नाम था वो ठीक है और ये
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है
आपको पता है की बहुत सारे इंटरफेस होते
हैं जिनका जरूरी है क्या नीची अलग से ही
हो|
अब इसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं आगे हम और
पीएफ को पढ़ेंगे लेकिन मतलब आउटसाइड को
पढ़ेंगे उससे पहले हम थोड़ा लेफ्ट की हर
एक टॉपिक से रिलेटेड जो भी लेयर जो भी चीज
हैं उनको एक साथ कर करते हुए चलेंगे और
कुछ चीज आपको भी ग रही होगी बॉडी बनाई गई
है वो आगे आपको बताई जाएगी तो ओवरऑल आपका
बेसिक से लेक अच्छी तरह से कुछ क्लियर
होगा तो आपको दिक्कत कोई नहीं होगी ठीक है
तो आपको ये मेरे साथ है की लेफ्ट करते
चलना है ठीक है जितने करूंगा जब आप वीडियो
देख रहे हैं अगर आप अपने साथ-साथ मेरे साथ
कर सकते हैं साथ में फिर ये लाइव चैनल
रिकॉर्डिंग है अपनी सबसे कर सकते हैं वो
भी आप कर सकते हैं और नहीं तो दिमाग लगाइए
मैं तो जब मैं आंसर बोलने जा रहा हूं मैं
का रहा हूं आप सोचिए तो आप सोचिएगा जरूर
मिलता है ठीक है तो पहले हमारा 501 पहले
आपकी फंडामेंटल वाले सारे करेंगे आज तो हम
थोड़ा ही करेंगे पूरा नहीं करेंगे लेकिन
धीरे-धीरे
यहां पे स्टार्ट करते हैं सबसे पहले चीज
यही है की नेटवर्किंग क्या होती है तो
यहां पे लिखिए जो मैंने अभी आपको बताया की
कई सारे कंप्यूटर का कई सारे डिवाइसेज जो
होते हैं वो आपस में कनेक्ट होते हैं अपने
इनफॉरमेशन को डाटा को एक्सचेंज करने के
लिए आपस में तो उसे एक्सचेंज करने वाली
प्रोसेस के लिए जो हमें किस जरूर है वो
उसे हम नेटवर्क कहते हैं मतलब उन सारे
कंप्यूटर के या डिवाइसेज के कनेक्शन को हम
नेटवर्क्स कहते हैं ठीक है लिखिए आप इसको
पढ़ सकते हैं इसमें जो भी नई चीज दिखेगी
मैं आपको बताऊंगा ये अब देखिए जैसे यहां
पे एग्जांपल दिया हुआ है और ट्रैकिंग का
इस्तेमाल में बेसिकली इसीलिए कर रहा हूं
की ये बहुत बढ़िया मुझे एग्जांपल सबको
चित्र के द्वारा फोटोस द्वारा वीडियो
द्वारा दिखा देते हैं ठीक है इसीलिए हमने
इस्तेमाल कर रहा हूं ट्राई करके ताकि आपको
अच्छे से बन जाए जैसे आप लिखा हुआ है की
एलिस से बॉब है और जिन है तीनों का अपन
बात करनी है तो तीनों एक नेटवर्क फॉर्म कर
रहे हैं ठीक है नेटवर्क कम कर रहे हैं
जिससे वो एक दूसरे पे डाटा एक्सचेंज कर
सकते हैं
तो पहले क्वेश्चन यहां पे क्या है व्हाट
इसे डी की ट्रक पर डिवाइसेज डेट एन कनेक्ट
टुगेदर
रखते हैं हम क्या कहा जाता है
ठीक है तो ये सही हो गया ऐसे आपको आंसर
सबमिट करते चलना है ठीक है
व्हाट इसे इंटरनेट पर एक बहुत बढ़िया
एग्जांपल दिया हुआ है इसके लिए तो आप मां
लीजिए अभी इमेजिन कर सकते हैं की एक कंपनी
है वहां पे तीन लोग कम कर रहे हैं ठीक है
बॉब जिम और एलिस ठीक है
कोई कंट्री के तीन एजेंट है मतलब आर्मी
से कोई भी गवर्नमेंट बॉडी है ठीक है अब
इसमें इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है की वर्ब ने जिम
से इनफॉरमेशन
मतलब आपस में इनका जो भी इनफॉरमेशन चेंज
है आपस में इन तीनों का हुआ ठीक है अब ये
सब एक्सचेंज खत्म हो जाएगा
दूसरी कंपनी में कम करते हैं दूसरे देश के
लोग हैं ठीक है
बाबा जी के साथ गद्दारी कर दी खाने का
मतलब बॉब और जब में जो भी डाटा इनफॉरमेशन
या सिगरेट चीज है और उससे ग्रेट हो पब्लिक
को जो भी चीज हो जो भी बताई थी उसने जैन
और टॉपिक होता है ठीक है क्या चीज हुआ था
की बम और जय नहीं जानते थे की जय हो तो
अभी कौन है ठीक है डायरेक्टली मतलब
डायरेक्टली उनका असर नहीं जानते थे ठीक है
ये भी आप सुन सकते हैं की बॉब जी थी ठीक
अब इस तरीके से समझ सकते हैं
खाने का मतलब ये थी की बाबर जी ने जो
इंटरेक्शन किया है वह अली से किया है ठीक
है
तो अभी तक कैसे पहुंचाना है वो कम किसने
किया उसने किया मतलब एलिस बीच में एक नोट
की तरह कम कर रहा है ये बीच में कनेक्शन
हिंदी आई है ठीक है
ऐसे काफी आराम कर रही है यही कम इंटरनेट
करता है खाने का मतलब बहुत सारे सब
नेटवर्क्स को आपस में जॉइन करता है तो सब
नेटवर्क्स का एक जो जॉइंट पूरा मतलब एक वो
है उसको आप का सकते हैं की ये इंटरनेट के
राहत है ठीक है ये डेफिनेशन आपको
स्टैंडर्ड डेफिनेशन जो है मिलेगी की
इंटरनेट का जो भी मेरे ख्याल से आगे भी
लिखा होगा हां देखिए इंटरनेट इस वन जय
नेटवर्क डी कंसिस्ट ऑफ में में स्मॉल
नेटवर्क्स तो ये चीज है ठीक है इंटरनेट
यही होता है अब इंटरनेट डिस्कवरी कैसे हुई
डब्लू डब्लू किसने बनाया ये सब यहां देख
सकते हैं तो इन चीजों का फॉक्स नहीं
करेंगे वरना ये चीज आपको करनी है आप कर
रहे होंगे तो ठीक है यहां पर ये कौन सा
दिया हुआ है यहां पे अलग-अलग नेटवर्क्स
हैं इन नेटवर्क कनेक्ट है और ये सब जाके
जुड़ जाना है इंटरनेट से ठीक है मतलब ये
सब मिल के इंटरनेट बना रहा है ठीक है तो
लेटर दो टाइप के होते हैं प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क
ठीक है
आईडेंटिफाइंग
नेटवर्क
ठीक है हां तो यही दिया है की जो ऐसे जो
होते हैं नेटवर्क पे वो ह्यूमन की तरह
होते हैं मतलब फिंगरप्रिंट पे पहचानिए ठीक
है ना!
फिंगरप्रिंट
करते हैं
ठीक है
अब देखिए मैं दोबारा कर रहा हूं तो ये
देखिए
हमारा आईपी एड्रेस नहीं शो करना है ठीक है
ऐसा क्यों नेटवर्क गया आईपी एड्रेस गया
ठीक है ये कॉन्सेप्ट है
ओके ठीक है
यहां पे मेरे ख्याल में दिया हुआ है तुम
थोड़ा डिटेल में बात कर लेते हैं और उसके
बड़े में
स्किप
एग्जांपल
नेटवर्क है ठीक है
वो एक वीडियो जो होता है वो आपका प्राइवेट
ठीक है वो आपके सिर्फ नेटवर्क के अंदर
नेटवर्क के अंदर ही हो सकता है लेकिन जब
आप नेटवर्क से इंटरनेट करते हैं
वहां पे पब्लिक आईपी एड्रेस का उसे होता
है ठीक है मतलब आप भी सिस्टम पर दो आईपी
एक प्राइवेट एक पब्लिक अब मैं थोड़ा इसको
डिप्रेशन समझाऊं तो पब्लिक सिलेक्ट कर रहा
है तो आप इस सिस्टम के पास नहीं है की
आपका राउटर के पास है ठीक थोड़ा आगे जब
मैं करूंगा ये इमेज क्लियर होती चली जाएगी
आपके मां में फिलहाल दो आई फूल होते हैं
पब्लिक और प्राइवेट ठीक है प्राइवेट मतलब
अपने नेटवर्क के अंदर जो आईपी है आपका
प्राइवेट हिप है आपका इंटरनेट से
आईडेंटिफाई हो रहा है वो आपका पब्लिक आई
है ठीक है
अपनी बैंड किया आईपी है गई दोबारा कनेक्ट
किया आईपी चेंज हो गई ये डायनेमिक होती है
इसका कोई फिक्स नहीं राहत ठीक है ए जाए ये
कल जाएगी दूसरी कुछ ठीक है इसमें डायनेमिक
है स्टेटिक मतलब जितनी बार कनेक्ट करें
आपकी वही रहेगी ठीक है ये एग्जांपल इसका
कंपनी होते हैं
ठीक है ना तो स्टडी करना पड़ता है
प्रोविजंस क्लासेस और सबनेटिंग यह चीज के
बड़े में भी हम पढ़ेंगे आगे तो आईडेंटिफाई
नेटवर्क वही चीज आईपी एड्रेस और नए एड्रेस
के बड़े में बताया जाएगा विपरीत देख लेते
हैं तो यहां पर वही चीज लिखी है ये आपका
इन वर्जन 4 की बात कर रहा है ठीक है देखिए
इनफॉरमेशन
था ठीक है तो इनमें से डॉट की पहले बात ये
सब कुछ कर हिस में डिवाइड किया गया है
इनको ऑस्टेड कहा जाता है ठीक है ऑक्टेंट
वन अपडेट तू अपडेट थ्री अपडेट फोर लिख
सकते हैं आप अब आगे देखेंगे जीरो से 255
क्या है आईपीएल एड्रेस जिओ मतलब यहां लिखा
है वहां जीरो से लेक 265 तक हो सकता है
यही से चीज चारों और कितने पॉसिबल है ठीक
है तब कहेंगे ऐसा क्यों हो रहा है ऐसा
इसलिए हो रहा है क्योंकि जितने कंप्रेशन
बन सकते हैं वो मुझे इस तरीके से बनते हैं
अगर आप बाइनरी नंबर में आते हैं ठीक है तो
एक दो तीन कर पांच छह साथ आठ ठीक है
एक दो तीन कर पांच छह साथ आठ फिर एक दो
तीन कर पांच छह साथ आठ एक दो तीन कर पांच
छह साथ आठ अब ये क्या हुआ 8 8 8 8 कितना
हुआ 32 इसीलिए मैंने कहा 32 बीट का होता
है फिर एक बीट में जीरो है ठीक है तो ये
जो एड्रेस आपको बनेगा
वो बनेगा
8 बन रहा है
यह वन है ठीक है इससे आपका क्या बनेगा
जीरो जीरो से लेक 255
तक जाता है इतने कांबिनेशन जो है पॉसिबल
है ठीक है
अब देखिए मैंने आपको ये चीज का यहां पे
आपका क्लासेस के बड़े में लिखा है थोड़ा
सा बेसिक चीज ये मैं बताऊंगा आपको भी आगे
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अगेन आपको से चीज दी
हुई है की आईपीएल देखिए ये आपका एक डिवाइस
है ये एक डिवाइस है ठीक ये दोनों लिखा हुआ
है और नीचे लिखा हुआ है
अब इन डिवाइस के पास दोनों के पास एक ही
प्राइवेट है देखिए कंप्लीट जो मैंने आपको
भी बताया था ठीक है ये प्राइवेट है इनके
नेटवर्क के अंदर का है ये पब्लिक इनके लिए
इंटरनेट एक्सेस करने के लिए है ठीक है
स्क्वायर में बताऊंगा
यहां पर
तो ये क्या था मेरे 19
अगर मैं गूगल करता हूं यहां पर
और थोड़ा आगे समझेंगे लेकिन अभी के लिए
समझिए की प्राइवेट है पब्लिक यही है ठीक
है प्रैक्टिकल प्रैक्टिकल लेवल
दिया है
यहां पर जो मैंने कहा था आपको इस तरीके
दिखता है 128 का ठीक है जो फोर्थ है वो 32
बिट्स का था ठीक है बिट्स का मतलब क्या था
मैंने आपको दिखाए
उसको हमने क्लास के बेसिस पे डिवाइड किया
था ठीक है जैसे क्लास एक ही आईपीएल जिनकी
रेंज यहां से यहां तक की है रेंज देख सकते
हैं यहां पर और इनका डिफॉल्ट मतलब क्या है
इसको मतलब कुछ नहीं दूंगा अभी आगे ये आपको
सबमटिंग इधर कम आता है ठीक है अब ये समझिए
की वन सेल यहां से लेक जितने भी एड्रेस है
सब रिजल्ट किया गए हैं और क्लासेस के
हिसाब से डिवाइड किया गए हैं ठीक है जैसे
यहां लिखा है क्लास ए एड्रेस इतना कनॉट बी
यूज्ड पर लूप बैक टेस्टिंग ठीक क्लास एक
जो एड्रेस है ये वन डॉट जीरो ये वाले ठीक
है जो भी दिए हुए हैं ये इनमें से इतना
पार्ट यानी ठीक है
टेस्टिंग के लिए लूप बैक मतलब ये है की आप
ऐसा होता है जो आपको सिस्टम का ये पेड़
नोट करता है
जैसे मैंने आपको बताया था इंटरफेस येलो
वाला तो वही चीज है बेसिकली ये समझिए की
आपका जो भी मतलब पॉसिबल है उनको रंगीन में
डिवाइड कर दिया गया है
ठीक है अलग-अलग कम के लिए जैसे मोस्टली हम
जो प्राइवेट
इनमें से ही ड्राइव होता है वो हमारा
हाइब्रिड से मुश्किल 192.168 से ही शुरू
होता है ज्यादातर ठीक है तो इस तरीके से
आप समझ सकते हैं और नीचे वाले ये एड्रेस
एक्सपेरिमेंट के लिए मतलब एक्सपेरिमेंट के
लिए जो है रिजर्व है हमारी उसे नहीं होता
है ना और रिजल्ट्स पर मल्टी कास्टिंग या
मल्टी कास्टिंग के लिए मतलब इन सबसे अपना
कुछ कम है ठीक है इस पे भी डिवाइड कर दिया
गया है अब इसमें डिफरेंस क्या है हर एक
मतलब क्लास मी का मतलब क्या है मतलब ये है
की हर एक क्लास में अलग नंबर ऑफ डिवाइस
फ्रॉम कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं इस तरीके से आप
समझ सकते हैं ठीक है कैसे जैसे मां लीजिए
वो क्लास सी की बात करते हैं जो मैंने कहा
की मैं वो प्राइवेट नेटवर्क इस्तेमाल करते
हैं तो क्लास सी की बात करते हैं क्लासी
में क्या होता है आपका अगर मैं दिखता हूं
आपको इस तरीके से
तो आपका इसमें क्या होता है तीन आफ्टर जो
होता है क्लास
सी हो जाता है ठीक वो सेट होता है मतलब वो
फिक्स होता है
वो फिक्स रहेंगे ठीक है जैसे आपका
ठीक है ना आठ मिनट
ठीक है
पॉसिबल
स्टार्टिंग
नंबर है इधर आपके डेसिमल नंबर है ठीक है
डेसिमल नंबर उसे करते हैं डेली लाइफ में
वो चीज हैं ठीक है ना तो ये वही चीज मतलब
इसमें मैंने कहा की यहां से लेक यहां तक
इस नेटवर्क में ठीक है
तो इस तरीके से डिवाइडेड सारा अब क्लास से
हमें अलग रेंज होती है क्लास में अलग मतलब
होते हैं इसी में 16 होते हैं आठ होते हैं
तो इससे क्या होता है की हम जितने
मा जाते हैं ठीक है ना तो यहां पे अभी हम
कर सकते हैं अगर उसको चेंज करेंगे ठीक है
तो ये फिक्स्ड है इसके बड़े में पढ़ सकते
हैं
फिर भी आगे हम और देखेंगे इनके बड़े में
चल रहा है
ठीक है ना
जो मुझे एक्स्ट्रा ग रहा है वो मैं अपनी
तरफ से एड कर दे रहा हूं ठीक है
इसके बड़े में कोई नहीं क्लास में सभी ये
कॉन्सेप्ट होता है
हमें जो इनका आईपीएस का क्लासेस डिवीजन की
वजह से आईपी एड्रेस का एफिशिएंट उसे नहीं
हो का रहा था मतलब जो समझिए की क्लास में
अगर 100 आपके जो है देवदास फैमिली ठीक है
और हमारे एक नेटवर्क
कम पद जा रहे हैं हजार रिपीटर ज्यादा पद
जा रहा है इस को जरूर नहीं है तो उसको
मैनेज करने के लिए हमने
क्लास लेस्बियन का इस्तेमाल किया ठीक है
क्लासिक मतलब ये है की कितने बीट हमने
फिक्स रखना हैं और कितने हैं वो हमारे ऊपर
है ठीक है ना उसके हिसाब से नंबर ऑफ गैस
कितने हम जोड़ सकते हैं और उसे नेटवर्क्स
में हम सब नेटवर्क्स कितने बना सकते हैं
ठीक है वो सब कस्टमर भी हो जाते हैं ये सब
ठीक है तो वो हम आगे पढ़ेंगे कोई मिलेगा
की ये चीज है ये भी है ये क्या कॉन्सेप्ट
होता है
मीडिया एक्सेस कंट्रोल एड्रेस ठीक है
नंबर सिस्टम
देती है और ये हमेशा से राहत है
चेंज हो जाएगा कभी चेंज नहीं होगा ठीक है
हार्डवेयर का वही एड्रेस होता है जो की
बेड एक चीज मिल जाति है आपको एड्रेस थोड़ी
डर के साथ आपके निकल के साथ और 16 गए ठीक
है ये क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं तो आईपी का
फूल फॉर्म क्या होता है ये पूछ रहा है
ठीक है
कनेक्ट है अब यहां पर क्या हो रहा है ये
हमारा एक राउटर है हमें लीजिए और ये हमारा
टारगेट यहां तक हमको उसे करना है ठीक ये
दो कंप्यूटर है एलिस और बॉक्स ठीक है की
आप अपने कॉलेज में है और एलिस एडमिन है वो
आप खुद ही है ठीक है ना आपको ऐसी कोई सोशल
मीडिया जो आपके कॉलेज में ब्लॉक कर राखी
है ठीक कम कैसे करता है ये ब्लॉग्स कम
करता है
जो हार्डवेयर है उसका एक एड्रेस है ये
एड्रेस है उसके लिए ऐसी
चेंज हो गया
टॉयलेट में चली ए रही है लेकिन जब यही
रिक्वेस्ट बॉब कर रहा है रिक्वेस्ट
में चली गई मतलब इसने इसको सर्व तक नहीं
जान दिया इससे क्या हुआ की आपने सुना पर
अपने channel.com नहीं खुला इस तरीके में
हमेशा मीडिया एक्सेस कंट्रोल यानी सवाल
होता है उसका रीजन क्या मैंने पॉजिटिव
बताया की मैं एड्रेस फिक्स राहत है अगर हम
आईपी चेंज करेंगे तो उससे ब्लॉक परमानेंट
नहीं रहेगा ना तो मैं एड्रेस कमेंट राहत
है
ठीक है
दोस्तों सवाल करते हैं तो आपको करने के
लिए और मैं कैसे नेटवर्क के अंदर इस्तेमाल
कर रहे हैं एक बार आप नेटवर्क के बाहर का
इंटरनेट
से कम्युनिकेशन होता है
अब यहां पे हम क्या करने वाले हैं मुझे
समझा अब ऐसा सुनाया है की अगर आपको बॉब पे
थ्रू इसको एक्सेस करना है तो कैसे करेंगे
मैंने आपको बताया था जब भी नेगेटिव को
चेंज करते हैं इसका मतलब जबरी चेंज हो
सकता है की कैसे होता है वो हम आगे
पढ़ेंगे पर फिलहाल इसका एक इंपैक्ट जरूर
देखें ठीक है इनफैक्ट कैसे ये देखिए ये
मैं क्या करता हूं एलिस का नया एड्रेस मैं
कॉपी करता हूं ठीक है और यहां पर बॉब का
मैक एड्रेस मिला के अंदर पेस्ट कर देता
हूं
और अब मैं बॉक्स से रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं ये
देखिए अब जब मैंने अपनी डेट है
ठीक है ये कैसे हो गया अब जो राउटर था
उसको लगा की ये जो रिक्वेस्ट है ये वो भी
लक की तरफ से ही आई है लेकिन
भेज रहा है
इसकी रिक्वेस्ट सेंड हो गई ठीक है ना अगर
मैं कैटरर्स बॉब का होता तो रिजेक्ट हो
जाता है
ऐसे ही कम करती है और इन तरीके से कर सकते
हैं
बता दूंगा
ठीक है
तो हर तरीके से होता है
चेंज होते हैं ठीक है ना तो यह
दो तरीके हैं
किस तरीके से डाटा को भेजना है दूसरी
कंप्यूटर पे ठीक अब इनके बड़े में थोड़ा
और
अभी इसके बड़े में
ओवरव्यू यही है ठीक है
कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड प्रोटोकॉल का कनेक्शन
प्रिंटेड मतलब पहले दो सिस्टम करना है
पहले सिस्टम में दूसरे सिस्टम के साथ
कम्युनिकेशन बनाया कम्युनिकेशन
हो जाए ठीक है इसलिए थोड़ा स्लो राहत है
कनेक्शन बनाने की कोई जरूर नहीं है
कनेक्शन
भेजना के लिए
चलिए
रिपोर्टिंग का कर सकते हैं इसका में
रिपोर्टिंग का होता है कनेक्शन
168 और 2 38 और 45 और मेरा जो डिफॉल्ट का
ठीक है ये उसका आईपीएल है 192.168 238 डॉट
कॉम 13 तो हम क्या करेंगे इसको पिंक
करेंगे मैं लिखूंगा पी कोड सिर्फ जो भी
टारगेट रहते हैं उसको पी करेंगे हम
ये देखिए रिस्पांस ए गया है तो पी ये
मैंने यहां पे क्या किया पी बेसिकली
आईसीएमटी प्रोटोकॉल का इस्तेमाल करके आपकी
पैकेट भेजता है और वो पैकेट आपके जो रिसीव
हो रहा है तो वहां से आपको रिस्पांस ए रहा
है ठीक है तो हमने क्या किया हमने एलसीएम
की एक रिक्वेस्ट किया और सामने
हमको रिप्लाई किया ये वही रिप्लाई दे
देखिए ये रिप्लाई
मतलब कनेक्शन कर रहा है और सब कुछ सही से
कम कर रहा है ठीक है यानी ये डिवाइस
नेटवर्क पर है और हम इसे कर सकते हैं आराम
से ठीक है इसका
लिखना है
ठीक है
मतलब कर पैकेट भेजना हैं ठीक है ना सही है
मतलब इसके आगे हम अपना आईपी एड्रेस लिख
देंगे
एक दो तीन कर ठीक है
ना इसलिए
एड्रेस देखिए
अब इंट्रोडक्शन तू लेने ठीक है
जरूर शेर कीजिए
ना बिल्कुल
हमारे साथ जुड़ सके और 20 में ठीक है ना
इतना आप कर सकते हैं मेरे ख्याल से इसको
कर दीजिएगा
ना चलिए
थोड़ा सा करेंगे
स्वागत करने पड़ेगी
करते हैं मतलब ये कैसे कनेक्ट हो रहे हैं
किस चिकन है ठीक है अगर हमारे पास कोई एक
मीडियम जो है जैसे की आप बना हुआ है इसका
ब्राउज़र का यहां पे इसका जो है ना उसे
तरीके से और उससे साइड में कैरेक्टर है
ठीक है वायर जैसे भी मतलब तो इसका कहते
हैं स्टार्ट
है तो पैटर्न सॉल्व कर रहा है इसमें क्या
होता है की जी भी कंप्यूटर को जी भी
कंप्यूटर में बात करनी है वो डायरेक्टली
कर सकता है वीडियो वाले सेंटर जो है खाने
का मतलब अगर इधर से ही बैठा हुआ है इसको
इधर से जो इंटरेक्ट करना है तो ये अपनी
रिक्वेस्ट राउटर को भेजेगा
और वो कंप्यूटर आप मैंने रिप्लाई
देगी इस तरीके से आपका कम कर रहा है तो ये
महंगा होता है उसमें काफी आपको केवल करनी
पड़ेगी ये महंगी होती है ठीक है लेकिन
सबसे बेनिफिशियल और मैक्सिमम उसे टोपोलॉजी
यही होती है ठीक है इसके अलावा अगर फर्स्ट
फ्लोर जो होती है इसमें होता है सेंट्रल
केवल है और इसमें से पेट में नहीं होता है
मतलब किसी पेड़ के पेट में होता है
सेंट्रल भी वो मतलब स्टेम होता है
पतली उसे टाइप का ये ठीक है ना मैंने कब
की बाहर गई है इससे नोट्स निकले हुए हैं
सारे अलग-अलग कंप्यूटर है जो डाटा स्लो हो
रही है साड़ी इस में केवल की वजह से हो
रही है तो इसमें थोड़ा सा ब्रेक या कोई
दिक्कत आता है तो सारे कंप्यूटर फिट हो
जाएंगे ठीक है सारे कंप्यूटर जाएंगे
ठीक है ना रिंग तो प्रपोज में क्या है
सारे चीजों में कनेक्ट है मतलब यह इसका
कनेक्टर है इसमें क्या होता है
ठीक है इसमें क्या होगा अगर मां लीजिए ये
वाला कंप्यूटर पहले वाला ऊपर वाला ऊपर
वाला शेर करना है मां लीजिए अगर ये चल रहा
है
तो ये एक एक कंप्यूटर जाएगा मतलब इस वाले
को
इधर आएगा और फिर यहां से यहां ए जाएगा ठीक
है मतलब यहां से पहले इधर वाले में आया
फिर यहां से यहां आया ठीक है
मतलब एक ही कंप्यूटर में होते हुए तब पता
चला रहेगा तब वो अपने डेस्टिनेशन कंप्यूटर
में पहुंच नहीं जाता ठीक है ना तो मतलब एक
कंप्यूटर को दूसरे कंप्यूटर में पहुंचने
के लिए रास्ते में जितने भी कंप्यूटर है
सबसे गुजरा पड़ेगा ठीक है ये कॉन्सेप्ट हो
गई रिंगोलॉजी ये बेसिकली आपका कॉन्सेप्ट
ठीक है अब स्विच की बात कर लेते हैं स्विच
क्या होता है जैसे मैंने आपको कहा था की
यहां पर आपका एक सेंट्रल डिवाइस इस्तेमाल
हो रहा है ठीक है जो आपका आउटपुट हो सकता
है पीछे से क्या होती है पहले मैं आपको
बता देता हूं इसके लिए आप डोनेशन कर देते
हैं
टाइम मैंने अपने आपको बताऊंगा तो वो चिंता
नहीं करना है ठीक है ना
तीन तरीके
होता है ठीक है जो की आपको तीन कर पांच जो
है इसको आपस में कनेक्ट कर रहा है अब इसका
फायदा ये है ठीक है तीन कर पांच हो रहा है
तो किसी भी एक डिवाइस को अगर दूसरे पीरियड
में भेजना है तो वो डिवाइस डायरेक्टली
ऑपरेटर हो जाएगा ठीक है अब बेटा हम किसको
बोलते हुए जितने डिवाइस है सबके पास ए
जाएगा अब जी डिवाइस के उसे डाटा का कम
होगा वो उसे तरफ इसका कम नहीं होगा वो
उसको रखेगा
मतलब मैंने क्या भेजो ठीक है मतलब मैंने
इसमें नीचे की एक नेटवर्क
दे दिया अब जो उसने साइंस था उसने
रेस्पॉन्ड कर दिया इस तरीके से कम करता है
अब तो हमने कोई एड्रेस ही कोई जरूर नहीं
है आईपी एड्रेस या कोई भी कोई जरूर नहीं
है ठीक है ना क्यों क्योंकि मैं भेज रहा
हूं सभी के पास जा रहा है सब सिंपल
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन कर दे रहा है चलो भाई सब
लोग ले लो जिसके कम का वो रफी से कम करना
है
रेस्पॉन्ड करेगा ठीक है
कौन सी सबमिट डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन हो जाएगा फिर
रिस्पांस कम का है वो रखें इंस्टाग्राम का
नहीं है वो फेक दे तो हम एक बेनिफिशियल
चीज नहीं होती है ठीक है ना आप समझिए
अराइज हो जाते हैं इसलिए हमने इंट्रोड्यूस
किया स्विच अब स्विच क्या करता है 600
इंटेलिजेंट है और स्विच मैं कट इसका
इस्तेमाल करके क्या करता है की सही आदमी
कोई डाटा भेजता है मतलब इसमें क्या होते
हैं यहां पे अब हम ए जाते हैं इसमें भी
साथ में स्विच कुछ इस तरीके का होता है
स्विच में क्या अलग-अलग फोर्स होते हैं
मां लीजिए कोड वन फोर तू फोर थ्री फोर फोर
रहते हैं मतलब पहले इधर फोर्ट है ठीक है
ना अब 10 दिवस में करेक्ट है तो स्विच को
पता है की हर डिवाइस पे कौन से नए एड्रेस
कौन से पोर्ट पे कनेक्ट है ठीक तो इससे
क्या हो रहा है की जब मां लीजिए एक डिवाइस
बी को बेटा भेज रहा है तो बता रहा है उसको
भेजना है ठीक है ना तो आपके स्विच को पता
है ये चीज की टारगेट मतलब बी का मैं एक
ड्रेस कौन से पोर्ट पे है तो वो इस पोर्ट
की आपकी डाटा को भेज देगा ठीक और साथ में
तो यही पता है की आप कौन सी फोर्स में है
जब रिस्पांस आएगा तो फिर रिस्पांस आपकी
फोटो भेज देगा इससे क्या होगा की आपका
डाटा अगर आपको एक डाटा बी को भेजना है तो
वो डाटा बी पे ही जाएगा ये नहीं की बाकी
जा रहा है जैसे हम भी हो रहा था मुझे नहीं
हो रही है तो यहां मैं एड्रेस का इस्तेमाल
करके हमने डाटा को सही आदमी को भेज का रहे
हैं ठीक है इससे हमारा काफी जो है जो भीड़
भारती वो कम हो गई है बहुत सारे प्रॉब्लम
ए रही थी वो सॉल्व हो गए ठीक है ना ये कम
करता है कौन वर्ष स्विच अब राउटर क्या
करता है राउटर का कम होता है बहुत सारे
नेटवर्क स्टॉप करना अभी हम क्या कर रहे थे
एक नेटवर्क के अंदर ही कम कर रहे थे मतलब
ये सिस्टम
के अंदर हमारा कम सही चल अगर मैं नेटवर्क
को नेटवर्क कनेक्शन करना है मतलब हमें
अपने ही सारे जो इसको नेटवर्क इंटरनेट पे
एक्सेस करना मां लीजिए दूसरे नेटवर्क करना
है दूसरे वाले इंटरएक्टिव मां लीजिए आप
ठीक है आपको हमें जस्ट डायल आप अपने स्विच
कनेक्ट है उन्हें हमें इंटरनेट एक्सेस
देना है तो वो हम आउटर छोड़ देंगे राउटर
मतलब रूटीन रूटिंग करता है उसके बीच में
ठीक है तो इससे क्या हो रहा है ये आपका
कंप्यूटर है ये आपका कंप्यूटर भी है ठीक
है अलग-अलग नेटवर्क पे है स्विच ऑफ ट्रैक
कर रहे हैं यही कम जो है डाउट कर रहा है
तो अब मैं अगर आपको एक एग्जांपल बताऊंगा
अगर आप मुझे होम्योपैथी में आया होगा
जो भी है ठीक है इसमें क्या होता है
आपने उसमें वी-फी से मलिक आप कनेक्ट कर
रहे हैं पांच डिवाइस तो पांच डिवाइस के
पास अपना अपना नेगेटिव तो है ही अपना अपना
एक प्राइवेट आईपैड रखती है ठीक है लेकिन
अगर उनके पास अपना कोई खुद का पब्लिक है
ये एड्रेस नहीं है अब आप जो रोटरी लगवाएं
हैं उसमें जो वो केवल क्रैक करके गया है
आपके लिए आपका जो भी प्रोवाइड है जो कीमत
है वो आपको एक आईपी एड्रेस डीके गया है जो
की डायनेमिक एक चेंज होता रहेगा बावा के
साथ-साथ जब आप डॉक्टर बैंड करते हैं चेंज
हो जाता है ठीक है तो वो आपको एक आईपी
एड्रेस दिखे गया है ठीक है ना ओके राउटर
को ये कहीं पे दिल डीके गया है तो राउटर
के पास है तो जब आपके पास जो है इसमें से
कोई भी अगर इंटरनेट को एक्सेस करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है तो वो उसकी रिक्वेस्ट
राउटर के थ्रू होते तो इंटरनेट चली जाएगी
यानी अपने अट्रैक्शंस करके इंटरनेट पे चली
गई ठीक है
कौन सा आयतन के पास आया आउटर ने जिसने भी
रिक्वेस्ट किया था उसको वापस भेज दिया
इससे क्या होगा की प्राइवेट के पास है और
पब्लिक राउटर के पास है तो ये आपको पब्लिक
से चेक करना है यानी पब्लिक इंटर का यानी
इंटरनेट से ट्रैक करना है आपका राउटर का
पब्लिक एड्रेस तो अगर आप आम सेंस हो
जाएंगे तो आपको समझ में आएगा तो जरा
पब्लिक आईपी एड्रेस से आएगा क्योंकि आपके
पास में डिवाइस के पास पब्लिक आईपी एड्रेस
नहीं है मुझे पब्लिक आईपीएस है वो आपके
राउटर के पास है राउटर मतलब ये राउटर को
दो लैंग्वेज आई है पब्लिक वाली आप
प्राइवेट में बात कर रहे हैं प्राइवेट
टाइपिस्ट से और वो आपकी डाटा को नोट करके
ठीक है आपने रिक्वेस्ट किया था पब्लिक आई
थिंक से इंटरनेट पे एक्सेस कर रहा है आपको
रिस्पांस को ले ए रहा है और आपको प्राइवेट
आपके पास वापस भेज दे रहा है इस तरीके से
प्राइवेट करता है और इस तरीके से हम
इंटरनेट पे जो है कम्युनिकेट करते हैं
राउटर इस्तेमाल करते हैं ठीक है अब कहीं
की किताब
है तो नेटवर्क के अंदर जो कम्युनिकेशन है
वो बेसिकली
इंटर कनेक्शन
हो रहा है ठीक है ना
पढ़ेंगे
ठीक है
क्वेश्चंस तो आंसर कर देते हैं लेंस का
मतलब क्या है लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क ये आंसर
क्या करता है रूटिंग करता है
करेक्ट लोकेशन
है बाकी आपको में कम ये रहेगा आप मैं इस
वीडियो को सिर्फ इनफॉरमेशन से भारत हूं
इसको वो आपको पता चलना है ठीक है जितनी
चीज इसमें दी हुई है आपको सब पॉज करने
में मेरे स्क्रीन में
ठीक है
स्टार वाली होती है
इसमें क्या हो रहा है सारे यहां पर जो भी
है आपका जो डाटा है वो गोल-गोल फ्लो हो
रहा है ठीक है मतलब अगर यहां से यहां
भेजना है तो इसका मी कितना होता है
की यहां पर तप खुला हुआ है उसको इग्नोर की
जगह खुला हुआ है बेसिकली देखिए मैं साउंड
टेस्टिंग कर रहा था वो भी इसमें ये र गया
है चलिए तो यहां से डाटा जो है आपका इस
तरीके से ट्रांसफर हो रहा है ठीक है
आपका की अगर बीच में कोई भी एक कंप्यूटर
में कोई दिक्कत ए जाति है
तो अपना नेटवर्क
ट्रांसफर कैसे होगा और यहां वाले को नीचे
वाले ऊपर करना है और बीच के सिस्टम में
खराब हो गया बैंड हो गए तो कम तमाम हो गया
ठीक है ये इसकी बुराई है ठीक है
मतलब आपको फ्लैग मिल जाएगा लास्ट में तो
जैसे मैंने तीन कर
पी थी स्टार इस तरीके से होता है सामने को
दिखने स्टेशन ठीक है इस तरीके से होता है
रिंग ये हो गया अपने रिंग का तो ये देख
लिया लाइफ है स्विच और अब और आउटर वायर
में भी आप समझिएगा अच्छे से अब ये चीज अभी
आपको मेरी बॉडी ग रही हो
और अगर नहीं दिक्कत नहीं है इनका
प्रैक्टिकल काफी कुछ करने वाले हैं मतलब
नेटवर्क करेंगे नेटवर्क करेंगे देखिए तो
मजा आपको आएगा तो पहले थ्योरी जरूरी है
ठीक है इसलिए आपको समझा रहा हूं मैं
इसीलिए का रहा हूं वो आगे जैसे कट करते
जाएंगे तो मैं आपको जाऊंगा मैं ठीक है ना
अब देखिए चलते हैं
कंप्लीट करेंगे तो शेर करने के लिए आता है
आपको निम्न पे शेर करना है हमें टाइप करना
है और कमेंट जरूर करना है अच्छा लगा तो
प्ले कुछ नया कोई दिक्कत हो रही है समझना
प्रॉब्लम हो रही है कोई डाउट खराब कुछ
डाउट दिक्कत है कमेंट भी कर सकते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है सपोर्ट मिलेगा तब हमारा
बताइए कोई दिक्कत ए रही है उसे चीजों को
समझाएंगे उनको कोई दिक्कत नहीं है जो भी
आपको रख सके हम कोशिश करेंगे
कंप्लीट करना है साइड में देखा हूं कितने
का स्कोर है क्योंकि जितना दीप जाएंगे
लेकिन जो भी आएगा अपने बेस्ट ही आएगा
एकदम बराबर है ठीक है ना जो दिक्कत है ठीक
है आज की वीडियो में और करते हैं हमको
लेकिन आपको कोई जो भी मैंने टास्क दिया है
ठीक है